just like you would you know I think you
you do your best
in your faith in Europe you fight you
get a very very clear perspective very
quickly and you know I found that things
got so very clear for me and it allowed
me in my life now to really truly maybe
for the first time as a as an artist as
a human being to really enjoy the moment
to truly live with grace and be grateful
you know today for as an example you
know I must practice coming here and and
listen I I hope that I have integrity
when it comes to my work or how I how I
do it the fact that you know in a few
nights over 70,000 people will have paid
their hard-earned money to come and see
me play in Emily and I want to give them
value that's still a part of running any
business but I truly believe that I have
no business knowing what you think about
me it's not my business anymore my
business is to to be a happy person and
to take the best parts out of life and
to truly love what I do to love the
moments to not allow moments to take to
get the best of me to release to thrive
you know and thank God I am you know
this is the first time I've ever even
had a chance to speak like this on a on
a stage this this large or ever answer
these questions and I instead of talking
about the pain and the negativity of it
I would much rather take the opportunity
to
to just to really say thank you you know
to thank all of those people who sent
their their prayers who sent their well
wishes who who who heard for us we're
not the only family that's gone through
something like this and there's many
families and we just we were just more
than grateful for that love that love
that we got it kept us many days it's
hard for me not to get emotional about
it you know it kept us alive it kept us
going through and we are just so
grateful for the for the you know for
the for the all those people out there
because I know to them they were
strangers and you know from Argentina
where they had put signs up in the
football games that said for Senora to
to this country to my country to all
over the world well when it just just
meant more than people will ever know
and so I say that on behalf of my wife
you know thank you thank you thank you
thank you
you